Das wasser vor floridas küsten sieht aus wie vom blut getränkt die sogenannte rote flut entsteht durch die explosionsartige ausbreitung
von einzellern konkret handelt es sich um eine intensive algenblüte mit dramatischen folgen mehr als 100 tonnen
toter lebewesen wurden allein schon im august an die strände gespült die unzähligen opfer
delfine fische
meeresschildkröten seekühe und viele weitere große und kleine
meeresbewohner aber auch menschen sind bedroht wie dramatisch die lage vor ort wirklich ist wie die helfer mit der situation
umgehen und warum wir menschen schuld an der katastrophe haben das alles jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen und am ende
kündige ich noch eine ziemlich gute geile aktion an hoffe ich doch zumindest
Das ganze macht einen körperlich und seelisch
fertig sagt eine der helferinnen gretchen of well vor ort sie arbeitet für das wissenschaftliche meeres institut mode marine laboratory
in florida und sammelt mittlerweile schon seit wochen tag für tag die toten und halb toten tiere an den stränden
floridas ein hier stinkt es bestialisch
kein wunder in dieser todeszone das was hier passiert ist nicht weniger als ein wirklich
dramatisches massensterben fischkadaver über fischkadaver und stadt blauem wasser
vor malerischen stränden hat sich das meer hier in eine grün rötliche brühe verwandelt vor einiger zeit
waren die strände hier noch malerisch und gehörten mit dem zu bild zu den
beliebtesten urlaubsregionen der welt davon ist ja jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr zu spüren
verendet sind die tiere alle durch die sogenannte
rote thiede oder auch rote flut genannt ausgelöst durch eine sehr intensive algenblüte die den
sauerstoffgehalt im wasser senkt und zudem auch noch giftstoffe produziert unter den opfern sind auch schon mehr als zwölf delfine so viele tote tiere
werden sonst in einem ganzen jahr an den stränden in der region
aufgefunden die anfänge der roten flut fanden schon im vergangenen oktober statt jetzt hat sich die algenblüte massiv ausgeweitet
forschungsteams haben das massensterben vor allem an der westküste von florida registriert die rote flut erstreckt sich hier mehr als
320 kilometer an der küste entlang von kampa bis naples konkret werden die einzeller namens carina
briefes und die augen tierchen lena sangui näher für das massensterben verantwortlich
gemacht die einzeller schwimmen gegen die schwerkraft zum licht hin und können eine geschwindigkeit von einem meter pro stunde
erreichen sie greifen extrem in das ökosystem ein verfärben das wasser rot und produzieren eine reihe von giften diese sogenannten
breve toxine sind giftige
stoffwechselprodukte der alpen das problem sie können sich innerhalb der nahrungskette anreichern das heißt sie werden
immer mehr von toxinen belasteten fischen muscheln und krebsen kann das gift dann auch zum menschen gelangen bei uns wird solch eine vergiftung
neurotoxin
schellfischposten nsb bezeichnet die patienten und patientinnen leiden an husten kopfschmerzen
und tränenden augen die vergiftung gilt zudem als auslöser für asthma medien in der region
berichten bereits von vorfällen und es gibt warnhinweise den kontakt mit den algen und dem wasser unbedingt zu vermeiden
die meeresbewohner dagegen sind dem gift
schutzlos ausgeliefert das fatale die tiere nehmen das gift nicht nur über die nahrung sondern auch über die haut auf es führt zu koordinationsproblemen
orientierungslosigkeit und krämpfen und am schluss
spätestens durch den sauerstoffmangel zum tod zu der giftwirkung
führt die dichte an phytoplankton an der wasseroberfläche zu dem auch zu eben dem verminderten
sauerstoffgehalt und dadurch wird das massensterben weiter begünstigt die tiere ersticken
qualvoll das phänomen der roten flut ist übrigens nicht neu im gegenteil es handelt sich um ein uraltes
naturphänomen die einzelner kommen das ganze jahr über in den gewässern vor und die algen blühen
regelmäßig es gibt theorien nach denen das rote meer nach genau diesem phänomen benannt ist die us-regierung hat die erste red
an floridas küsten im jahr 1840 offiziell dokumentiert doch die ausmaße der gefährlichen algenblüte werden immer extremer
das hauptproblem sind zu viele nährstoffe die vor allem durch die menschen ins wasser gelangen diese lassen die algen
schnell wachsen und große bestände aufbauen experten und expertinnen zufolge liegt der ursprung des übels etwas weiter nordwestlich der aktuell betroffenen
regionen durch die überdüngung des mississippi gelangen zu viele nährstoffe in den golf von mexiko
doch man muss auch gar nicht so weit gucken um ähnliche prozesse zu finden auch in europäischen gewässern wie beispielsweise in großen teilen der ostsee
fehlt in den tieferen wasserschichten der sauerstoff der gouverneur von florida hat jedenfalls den notstand für sieben counties
ausgerufen und mehr als 1,5 millionen us-dollar für ein hilfsprogramm versprochen für die bewohner und bewohnerinnen
bleibt nicht mehr als aufzuräumen und zu hoffen dass die rote flut bald beendet ist
langfristig gesehen sind politik und landwirtschaft
gefragt der einsatz von dünger muss stark reduziert werden um neue todes bringen die fluten in der zukunft zu verhindern
und jetzt in eigener sache wir machen klicks um werbefrei keine priols mehr und ihr könnt das na ja fast
unmögliche möglich machen denn uns geht es nicht immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung von jeweils einem video im monat ab bis es vor keinem video mehr werbung gibt
wenn das nicht sensationell es wäre es also mitglied hier unter dem video oder auf dem kanal und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live streams und noch ein paar weitere privilegien einfach hier eben unter dem video auf mitglied werden klicken
tausend dank an diejenigen die schon dabei sind wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die bei einigen etwas unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video mehr einfach hier draufklicken
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
riesenproblem plastikmüll auch im meer was ganz schlimmes was hilft bis dann
bleibt dran